Hello everybody!
Hello guys!
I'm so excited.
I know this is like a super rare Sunday stream.
I figured since, you know, I took an extra rest day yesterday, I was like, ah, fuck it, let's do it.
Let's do a Sunday stream.
It's very rare.
It's very rare of me to do a Sunday stream.
But like, I took like an extra rest day last week.
So I'm just like, you know what?
Let's spoil the dragoons a little bit today.
You might be noticing lately that like, I've been posting schedules a lot earlier than I used to in the past.
If you are, if you're a new fan, in the past, sometimes I will post my schedules on like Tuesday or like Monday or something.
But lately, yes, I've been posting my schedules a lot.
That is because it is a lot easier to figure out what to play now.
I don't really have to wait on anything.
So other than like collabs, I guess collabs is like the only thing that I have to actually like wait for, for confirmation.
But usually I ask about collabs for like really early on before like the week is over.
So like I would know what the collabs are for next week, stuff like that.
Because I already do have like some stuff, some collabs planned for next week.
Like things like that.
Like I try to plan early for collabs.
So that's why I've been posting my schedules a lot earlier than usual.
I hope I will be able to keep that up.
Mui, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey Doki, can I get a birthday wish for my birthday today?
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Mui.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
But yeah, anyway.
Shadow of Colossus.
This is actually a game that I've been meaning to play for a very, very, very, very, very, very long time.
I sort of know what this game is about.
Because my very first time watching this playthrough was years, years, years, years, years ago on the Game Grumps.
Oh my gosh.
If I ever get a collab with the Game Grumps, it would be a fucking dream come true.
Anyway...
Is that... Egoraptor?
Anyway, I don't think he likes being called Egoraptor anymore.
I think Aaron wants to be called Aaron.
But like, anyway, anyway.
I've actually... that was like the first time I've watched...
Bro, you know he's like... I...
Okay, you know he's like...
Okay, I feel like saying this would be like, yeah, I'm not gonna collab with this bitch.
You know, Aaron is like 37 now.
Oh my god, I feel old now knowing that!
Aaron is like, he's almost 40!
I was like, what?
No, they're supposed to be like in their 20s forever!
Forever!
I can't believe it.
Time.
Shut up!
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
He's almost 40!
Oh my god!
I always feel like Game Grumps is always in their 20s forever.
They'll be in their 20s forever!
But he's... it just blew my mind.
It actually blew my mind that he's 37 now.
Stop talking!
Shut up!
Anyway.
But yes, the very first time I've ever watched this playthrough was via Game Grumps.
And it seemed like a game that I've always really wanted to play.
And I've always actually played...
I'm trying to remember the developer of Shadow of the Colossus.
Who are the developers of Shadow of the Colossus?
I talked about... I told this story before.
Oh, Team Ico?
Or ICO?
I don't know if it's ICO or ICO.
But basically, the only game I've ever played from them was the one regarding the Shadow people.
God, what was that game called?
I didn't... I was so young when I played that game.
Because I always saw it.
Saw like demos of it.
You could play the demo of it.
And then I was like, oh my god, dad, buy this game for me.
This... there's... the demo looks so fucking cool.
And then I bought the game.
And then... oh, it's the same.
It is also ICO.
Okay.
It's also... it's also ICO.
Anyway.
And then the thing is, I was a really stupid kid.
And I'm a very stupid adult too.
So like, you know, at least it's like...
At least I'm consistent.
You know, at least... at least I'm consistent in terms of like how this goes.
But basically, as a kid, I was really fucking stupid.
Never... didn't change at all.
Anyway, but... I tried to play it.
I bought the game and I tried to play it.
I had no idea what the fuck I was doing.
Because these games, there's no actual instructions.
It's all about using like... context clues and being intuitive.
But like, I didn't have that as a kid.
I still don't have that as an adult.
I think I was just born wrong.
But...
But like, I didn't know what the fuck to do.
Because all I could remember was just running around and slapping people with a wooden sword.
And I didn't know what to do.
I was so fucking frustrated.
I spent hours trying to...
Like, when I bought the game, I spent like hours...
Like, trying to play the game.
Trying to figure out what to do.
And I was just running around as this little kid.
Fucking whacking shadow people with a wooden sword.
And I was so fucking frustrated.
I was like, why do I have a wooden sword?
Where are the real weapons?
Where's the princess?
And then I stopped after that.
I literally played a couple of hours one day.
And then I never touched the game again.
I... I never touched the game again after that.
And that was my only experience playing their games.
And I never played any other games that they made.
Oh no!
That's a lie.
I played the Guardian.
It... it was also like when it came out.
It was a beautiful game.
But like... I think I... I also played for one day.
I played for one day.
Because I think I got stuck in an area.
Because like I said, these games...
They're... it's all about being able to figure stuff out yourself.
And then... so like I must have been stuck somewhere.
Because I got so fucking frustrated that I stopped playing after one day.
So... I am consistent throughout this.
And because of this...
But I saw... you know... I saw other game girls playing it.
And it seemed really fun.
So I was like, you know what?
Maybe this time it will be different.
Because this time I have chat to yell at me.
If I get lost.
Because I know for this game...
This game... the hour play through is really depends on like...
How many...
It really depends on where you know what to do.
Like where you have to go type deal.
Because if you know where to go...
This game is like 2 to 3 hours.
Because you're just going to destination, destination, destination.
If you don't know where to go... like me...
It can be a very long game.
So it really depends on like...
How this is going to go.
If I'm going to find...
The Colossus and shit like that.
If I'm going to find the big scary monsters that I have to kill.
Because it's all about trying to find the big scary monsters.
I have no idea... like obviously people...
I think the internet... yeah forums existed.
But like I'm pretty sure this game had a fucking game guide.
I am so 100% sure.
There has to be a game guide for this.
Because like...
How the fuck were people able to figure out where to go?
Like how... how the fuck were people able to figure this out?
Oh yeah and the lizards!
Oh I forgot about the lizards!
Apparently I have to fucking beat up some lizards too!
Oh my god for like extra health or something?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
I don't remember from the...
All my... all the knowledge I have is just from...
Like just sort of from...
Remembering from never on game grounds.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Oh to upgrade my stamina!
Yeah!
Fuck!
Okay this is gonna be...
This is gonna be interesting.
I hope you guys don't hate me too much for...
Ruining this game for you guys.
I hope...
I hope you guys don't hate me that much.
Also is my sound guy here today?
Oh photo mode.
Hell yeah.
Let's do photo mode.
Cinematic mode.
Performance mode.
No.
Midnight mode.
I don't know.
We'll just do that.
That seems fine.
I don't know if my sound guy is alive right now.
Let me double check.
He is!
Sound guy!
Okay don't worry sound guy.
He's here.
He typed to...
Sound guy!
You have a...
A YouTube account!
Use that!
Let me know you're here via YouTube.
Rock thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Getting lost.
Wanting back sync.
What I'm hearing is Doki needs other weapons.
I'm gonna go get some weapons.
Sound is in her life.
The game that tracks back seekers.
Thank you super chat.
Thank you.
I just...
Okay until only one...
Wait...
Where is the other one?
I don't even see the other.
There's another one?
I don't know.
I don't even see the other sigil...
By the way guys I still...
I still haven't upgraded my monitor so like my monitor is still the shitty one.
I might get a upgrade.
Upgrade soon.
And thank you for the five gift ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright.
I don't know if the name sounds gonna be...
I'm gonna boost it up a little bit.
There we go.
That should be good.
Right?
Bird!
Also, if I'm looking to the right a lot, it's because that's where chat is.
That's really it.
I'm just looking at chat.
LOL
Lore time!
Yeah, there's no like actual dialogue in this game.
That's me!
Smile.
And that's our horse.
I can't wait...
to kill only one boss in this game.
I bet you I'm gonna spend like...
half of this... 90% of stream just trying to find one guy.
LOL LOL Okay, you can bring it up more?
Okay.
Alright, let me know if that's better.
Ooh!
It's like the re- It's the PS4 version, so I'm pretty sure this is like the remake.
It's like... a little bit better.
Bum-ba-dum!
Alright!
Is the sound better?
Sound guy!
Bum-bum!
The soundtrack's beautiful though, I have to admit.
The soundtrack's really, really nice.
It's worse?
How can it be worse?
It's the PS4!
Normal size.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't be too hard on yourself, Doki.
I managed to find three bosses.
How can it be wor- There's 16 bosses?!
Okay, I did not realize there are 16 bosses in this game.
I don't know how the fuck I ha- I was able to watch 16 bosses.
That's me!
Yeah, the soundtrack is pretty amazing.
I heard that you're planning on releasing a new console soon.
For like, this year and ne- next year?
Maybe?
You're a nerd.
Shake my head!
Thank you for the super chat- What did I do?!
Moon, thank you for the first super chat to call me a nerd!
What the fuck did I do?!
You see, to be a nerd, you have to be smart.
There's no way the graphics are worse than the original PS2.
There's no fucking way.
You guys all have like fucking nostalgia glasses on if you think- If you think the original had better graphics.
The PS2 graphics- It's like, going back, you're like, oh yeah, that was the best fucking game I've ever played back in the PS2 era.
And you- You replay it now and you're like...
There was just nothing better to do.
Alright, settings.
Audio.
Look, the PS2 was great!
I would admit, I love the PS2.
But you have to admit that there's a lot of nostalgia factor going into the PS2.
Okay, nice.
Show tutorial.
That's what I need.
Uhhhh...
It controls... audio...
I think that's good, right?
Yeah.
We should be good now.
No- Of course there's no motion blur.
But what would the hard version be?
They'll be harder to find?
Like,
what's the hard version gonna be?
Will they be like harder to find?
Why?
How do you make this harder?
Oh yeah, instead of like in this open area, you gotta go to like all the way to the end of the map.
And then you're gonna find this one stone.
And you have to make sure you hit that one stone to be able to- To be- To be able to get there.
And then the boss will show up.
But then, when the boss shows up, that's not when you engage the fight.
Because after that, you have to find the third stone.
That's like on the other side of the map.
And then you hit that third stone.
And then you go back to the second stone.
And then he'll show- And then he'll show up.
That is the hard mode.
And like someone was like, you just get less stamina.
Oh, okay.
Someone was like, Doki.
You just get less stamina.
Well, I'm gonna find my princess.
The hard version, it's more cutscenes because you find out their backstory.
And then you take emotional damage on top of it.
Here's my dead princess.
God, the soundtrack is actually beautiful though.
It's actually- She's half dead?
I like think like- Who's feeding this woman while I'm like, you know, trying to find the bosses.
Sorry, video game logic.
I'm like so spo- Not spoiled, but I'm so corrupted by video game realism in the current times.
Because everything has to be super duper fucking realistic now when it comes to video games.
So now I'm wondering, what the fuck is like- It's like she's in a coma, right?
So when you're in a coma, you have to- You have to like make sure they don't get bed sores.
Which is basically if the skin has too much pressure, it starts like breaking apart.
And I'm gonna be gone for a long time.
Who's gonna bathe her and feed her and make sure she's like turned around.
Oh, she's actually dead dead.
Yeah, her blood was born and she's like, I am a monster.
I can't even move my head.
I'm a monster.
I'm so, so exhausted.
But I'm a bad monster.
I'm a bad monster.
I'm a god.
I'm a god, too.
I wonder if that's a real language.
Or if they were just like, just go wild, man.
Well, the Sims language is an actual language.
I've shown it before, but the Sims is an actual real language.
I'm just wondering if they... when they told the voice actor to like read this...
if they were like, just fucking go wild, man.
I don't know.
Yeah, it is.
If you like... there's like...
It's called Simlish.
Simlish or something?
And then there's like actual songs.
Wait, you guys don't know about Simlish?
Okay, after I kill these shadow people, I need you guys to listen to Simlish.
It's actually crazy.
Because like, they've had like real songs.
They've had real... I don't... okay, I might get demonetized.
But like...
They've had real songs translated into Simlish.
And they got like the actual rights off of it.
It's the best language.
Okay.
I'll show you guys after the gameplay.
I'll show you in the Super Chat reading.
We're gonna do Super Chat reading.
We're gonna do Super Chat reading today!
I'll show you in Super Chat reading.
It's actually crazy.
Alright.
Alright, princess.
Apparently you're actually dead dead.
And you're not in a coma.
I got one guide because somebody was like, oh no, she's like...
Nah, she's half dead.
And this is why you are a nerd.
Shake my head.
Thank you in the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Yes, I have the ancient sword.
That's me.
24 hour, your luck.还 Noel Wiechua yeah my girlfriend's dead.
Please.
I don't.
I don't think I can find another one.
Jacket.
What?
What the fuck?
I don't care about clothes.
Where I put my jacket?
That's expensive.
Look, Dormin, people die every day.
What makes her special?
There's so much fish in the sea, Dormin.
Why is she special?
Is it because she's a princess and you want to inherit her throne?
She is real to me.
Oh, I forgot Dormin is the...
Oh, sorry.
Dormin is the god.
I have to destroy the...
The Colossus.
Dear!
Sirp!
He's just like me for real for real.
Jesus Christ this is so much weird.
Bro just... bro!
Why is she so special to you?
You wouldn't get it.
It's called love.
Okay but like it's 16.
It's 16 fucking Colossus.
Like okay one or two.
That's fine.
16 for her?
What if she's 16?
She like breaks up with him later!
Doki you don't understand.
It's actually 17 because of the hidden one.
Okay I have to follow the light with my sword.
Worth it.
Bro if I'm like the chosen one.
Like any... wouldn't any women would be like oh my god I'm in love.
Okay there's my sword.
Now be on the way.
Okay how do I call my horse?
X is jump.
Alright.
Nice I know how to jump.
Hold up the sword using R1 and look at where the light being.
This way.
Oh.
Oh I have to follow the light.
Okay.
That's where the next Colossus is.
Uh she's a great kisser.
Alright hello Argo.
We gotta go find...
We gotta go find the Colossus for my girlfriend.
Okay to make Argo run faster.
How do I move with him?
Okay he has to be like...
Oh my god!
How do I go backwards?
Holy shit!
Okay Argo is so hard to control.
Oh...
Argo why are you so hard to control?
Oh my god.
Alright where the fuck is the salamander?
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh!
I am not having a good time.
Okay it's this way.
Okay Argo let's go.
Oh my god it's actually... this is too real.
Horse riding is actually so hard.
Oh my god alright.
Let's see.
Oh that's so hard.
This camera.
Guys this is not doing...
I'm not doing so well already.
Argo!
Let's go Argo!
Oh god okay let's go!
Oh my god!
It's too real!
Jesus Christ!
It's way too real.
I'm just gonna look at the sky.
I can't.
Argo is like...
Way too real.
Please!
Go forth!
Back up your... back up the trunk!
Right here.
Good.
Good job.
Holy shit.
I've never struggled so hard riding a horse.
Please!
Why does it tilt up?
I'm trying!
Oh!
Okay it's this way.
This is the way.
Please stop calling the horse Argo.
What is his name?
He's Argo now.
My favorite horse.
Argo.
Alright.
This way.
This way has to be it.
There's no other way.
Argo!
See?
Agro!
Oh!
I think Argo is a better name.
What did I do it?
Is this one of them?
Hello?
Is this the first Colossus?
Please.
Okay.
It's up right?
It's up.
Okay.
Please not.
Argo!
Alright.
We're gonna go...
climb.
How do I climb?
While holding R2 use L to climb.
Okay.
Wait.
Grab on the places.
But where can I grab?
I'm grabbing!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Can I?
Okay.
Wait I can fix the camera.
I...
Wait.
There's filters?
Oh my god.
I can make this look less sad.
Wait.
What?
There's filters in this game?
Wait.
This is great.
I can actually make this game look less sad.
Oh my god.
There's Sepia.
Make it...
Okay.
Wait.
We should make it like warmer.
Make it less sad.
Wait.
There's like...
complimentary.
Okay.
What's the difference between...
compliment... warm...
compliment... Oh my god.
This makes it like less sad.
Okay.
We're gonna do... We'll do warm.
Like as if the sun is still up.
And then we'll have...
There's death appeal.
There is death appeal.
What the f...
What does this look like?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Sorry.
Sorry guys.
I'm sorry.
This is like...
I'm sorry for distracting you guys with this.
Alright.
Here we go.
Now I should be able to climb, right?
Climb.
Why can't I climb?
Climb!
For the love of god!
Two!
Okay.
There we go.
Oh!
Bushes!
Alright.
It's the bushes.
I figured it out.
How do I get up though?
Do I... Do I go like...
here?
Oh!
I have to go this way.
Okay.
It's okay.
I still have a lot of stamina.
Come on.
Climb up.
That's it.
That's right.
Come on.
Come on!
Get up!
Oh my god!
Why are you so stupid?
Okay.
Don't worry.
We got this.
Here we go.
Now go.
Go.
Oh thank god.
Okay.
Come on.
Why did you jump?
Just get up!
Get up!
Oh my god.
Okay.
There we go.
Guys.
I'm figuring this out.
Okay.
We're learning.
We're learning here.
Alright.
Nice.
And then...
Climb.
Yes.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
Doki is like slowly conquering journalist mode.
Don't worry.
I'll be the... Oh!
Dive roll?
Oh!
I didn't realize there was a hole there.
Alright.
This is your second job as a journalist.
No.
I figured it out.
This is... Now you know why I quit eco so fast.
Now you know.
You know why I quit.
Wait.
Is there like a way to get up?
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
Grab.
Wait.
No.
Not grab this.
Is it this one?
No.
There's like...
Something I can grab.
Right?
Oh shit.
There has to be something I can grab here.
Alright.
Or maybe I have to grab it from here.
Right?
What do I grab?
Oh!
Please!
Grab the something!
Oh god.
Alright.
We're gonna figure this out.
You must be able to grab some...
The camera is showing you.
What?
This?
What do I have to grab?
What's the camera trying to show me?
Where's my...
Where's my yellow paint?
Oh!
I can grab to the left!
I'm learning!
Guys, I'm getting better!
My brain is actually leveling up!
I can't wait to go to graduate kindergarten!
You're the first!
You're the reason why games have yellow paint!
I am the consumer!
I am the regular dormi player base!
Okay?
I am the consumer!
Okay.
Hold R2 to focus on the colossus.
How do I use my weapon?
How do I use it though?
Oh, I can call my horse here.
Okay, I'm focused.
Hello, it's me.
I'm friend.
Friend?
Friend!
Oh shit!
Sorry!
Wrong weapon!
Oh friend!
Okay.
Friend!
Where's your weak spot friend?
Where is it?
Where's your weak spot?
Oh wait, I have to bring down...
Oh god, where's the settings?
I have to bring down the music just a little bit apparently.
Okay.
Alright, let me know that's better sound guy.
Friend!
Where's your weak spot?
Where the fuck is it?
Oh, it's head!
Okay, don't worry friend.
I'm gonna climb on top of you.
And then I'm gonna give you a nice little surgery.
Don't worry.
Friend.
Hold press the ring, press the stab again.
Okay.
Can I stab this?
Friend!
Oh shit!
Don't worry!
I'm like a little bug scratcher!
I'm just gonna give you like a little help.
Woah!
God, please.
Just let me do a little poke.
Yeah!
Just a little poke!
Come on!
Yeah!
It's gonna be okay!
Friend stab!
Good friends will stab.
Bro, you have like a pimple trying to pop your pimple!
Okay, here we go.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
Friend's here.
Friend is here.
Sorry, I need to aim.
Friend needs to aim a little bit better.
Here we go.
Boop!
Do you like that little back scratch?
See?
He liked it!
Climb.
Okay.
Oh god, I have to climb so far.
Climb!
No!
God!
Okay.
Climb here.
Okay, we're okay.
We just need to recharge our stab.
No!
What the fuck?
Bro.
We're like the most annoying...
We have to be like the most annoying mosquito ever.
Like annoying flea or some shit.
Okay, we're good.
Friend, climb.
Climb.
It's okay.
Don't worry, Friend.
I'm gonna help you.
Friend, don't worry.
You have a bug issue.
Don't worry, Friend.
Oh, Friend.
Please.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Oh god.
Okay, how the fuck do I stay?
AHHHHHH!
STAB!
Friend stab!
There you go.
We're okay.
That's okay.
He likes it.
It's like a little poke... a little head pat.
Guys, it's just a little head pat.
Nothing to worry about.
See?
He likes it.
We're like best friends now.
We're like best friends.
Hahahaha!
Hahaha!
Oh, I have to fucking hold it!
To stab longer!
Oh, no!
No!
Okay, okay.
It's fine.
I just realized what I was doing wrong.
Hahaha!
I was just doing little...
Oh, no!
Nooooo!
Guys...
I realized I had to...
I had to like... recharge my stamina.
I had to like...
recharge my stamina.
For a little bit.
Sorry.
Look!
It's like my first job!
I'm like shadowing right now.
Stab!
I did it!
Alright, I figured it out.
Guys...
I'm not annoying anymore.
I'm just... I'm actually...
I'm actually trouble this time.
I'm not annoying this time.
I'm actually like...
a problem.
Because I figured out how to...
I figured out...
how to actually hurt him.
Alright, here we go.
At first, I was just like, you know...
a little bug bite.
You know, just a little tiny bug bite.
And now I'm like... I'm like a real problem.
Hahaha!
Boom!
There we go!
Don't worry.
It's like...
It's like just some therapy.
Some brain therapy.
Right here.
Look at that!
We're getting rid of all the...
toxic juices in your brain!
Have you seen that?
Where like they do this like...
fucking thing where they actually...
try to gush out liquid from your head?
Yeah, I'm just doing some acupuncture.
Yeah, the oil drill!
Yeah,
the oil drill!
Yeah, the oil drill!
This is the oil drill!
I saw like...
It's okay.
Don't worry.
I purified you.
See?
All better now.
Yay!
We did it!
We got the first pause!
That's so easy!
Was that him?
He's a happy customer.
He came back to...
wish me a well... good job.
No, it's like a happy customer!
It's like...
Good job, Doki!
I was so stressed out and now I feel...
relieved.
He's leaving a Google review!
That's my Google review right there.
Yeah, it must be a good thing...
you're doing because of all the...
black spirits.
It's like oil!
That's why it's black.
Look at that.
He was so happy.
He like...
gave me more space.
That's the tip.
That's my next vo.
I can move the camera!
Oh, it's the water!
That's like a house upgrade.
You know like in Animal Crossing?
Where your house gets bigger?
Now I have more space to put my...
storage cabinet.
Nice.
Argo, are you back?
Guys, I figured out how to play the game.
Alright.
Our next step is to find the fucking salamander.
Argo!
You came back!
I need to figure out how to ride this horse.
Okay.
I think this is like the hardest part of the game.
Oh my god.
This is actually...
This is actually the hardest part.
I should have found an altar similar to this one.
Wait, I'm injured?
What do you mean?
I thought there was no fall...
There's fall damage in this game?
What hurt me?
There's no way.
Am I actually injured?
I can't tell.
There's no bars or anything.
Hello.
Did I save?
Oh, it's a save station.
Hello.
Save.
I think...
I think I saved?
I can't tell.
Oh, I have the...
prey?
Oh shit.
Okay, sorry.
There we go.
Save.
Oh, I have the...
save.
Prey to save.
Here we go.
I figured it out.
Prey to save.
Nice.
Alright.
Alright, Argo.
Let's go.
Where do we go?
Where is the sword taking me?
Where is it this time?
Below?
Why is it pointing that way?
How do I go below?
What?
Okay.
Little me would never play this game.
That's for sure.
Thank god I have chat.
Okay, this way.
Wait, what?
It has to be like...
behind, right?
Oh my god.
Argo, please.
Please.
Alright.
We gotta figure this out.
Argo, please!
I keep pressing X.
He likes to ride the horse.
But it's triangle.
Alright.
It's like somewhere around here.
Oh!
Is it behind the temple?
It must be.
Yeah.
It's somewhere behind here.
Okay.
Camera.
Camera, work with me.
Please.
Please work with me.
Okay.
It has to be like...
behind here.
Behind here?
Because why would it take me here?
I have to climb the temple.
Okay.
Let's see.
Sword.
Where do I go, sword?
Where do I go?
Sword!
Tell me!
Where shall I go?
Where's the sun?
Okay.
There's the sun.
Alright.
Sword, guide me.
Guide me, sword.
Sword, you must know.
Below?
How the fuck do I go below?
It's a cave somewhere.
GPS!
Oh!
Down here!
Will I die?
Well, time to find out.
Go!
If you...
I'm not afraid.
I'm not...
What are you afraid of?
It's Wadi!
Yeah!
Hey, I think I'm dead.
Wait, am I...
Am I...
I'm dead!
Guys, I think...
I like...
Okay.
I like that...
I like...
It's not... It's not even a splash!
It's not...
It's not even a splash!
There's like...
There's... Like, I don't even sink down!
It... It's...
It's just like... I just...
No way...
Oh my god!
Like, he doesn't even sink!
That's the crazy part!
He just fucking...
It was like concrete!
That is so realistic, not gonna lie.
It has to be like the most realistic water... water physics ever.
Just like real life.
I don't know.
Usually, you know, it's like Minecraft.
When you drop down, like, you don't die from the water.
I thought it'd be like Minecraft, where you can stop the fall.
I realized it was not like Minecraft.
I realized...
I...
Today, I realized it was not like Minecraft.
Heh heh heh heh heh heh...
Heh heh heh heh heh...
Okay, how do we get down then?
We have to figure out how to get down.
Because the cave is down there.
Like, it's still water!
It can't be that bad!
No bucket tech.
Where's the bucket tech here?
How the fuck do we get down there?
There's a bridge?
Oh, there is a bridge.
How do I get to the bridge?
How did I get to the bridge last time?
There has to be like another bridge here.
This one, right?
Yeah, this bridge.
Okay.
Yeah, I know I could climb down.
But like...
That's not fun.
Heh heh heh heh heh heh...
Heh heh heh heh heh...
It's not as fun as falling... It's like the biggest dive board.
You know?
It's like the biggest fucking diving board.
I mean, the Olympians can do it.
Why can't I?
You know?
I mean, did you see...
Whoa!
Oh shit.
Where is that?
I mean, did you not see me climb the fucking Colossus?
Let R go dive.
Oh, it's down there.
Okay.
What?
Did I ever jump down?
Heh heh heh heh heh heh...
Heh heh heh heh heh...
So many questions.
I wanna know how...
How many ways can I die?
Jump, Argo.
Jump.
Alright.
Yeah.
Come on, Argo.
We need to be a little faster.
There's no fast travel in this game.
Alright.
Don't...
Don't keep... please.
I haven't found a single salamander yet.
Or like, stamina.
They must be like so fucking tiny, cause I don't know where they are.
Okay, where's my sword?
Oh, there's no sun.
This is bad.
I'm gonna go with intuition.
And it's like somewhere here.
I swear, there was like side... like there was like a boom boom boom here, right?
Whoa.
There he is.
He seems friendly.
Look, another customer!
The first colossus must have left a really good review.
I already have a second customer.
Don't worry, sir.
I'm ready to give you some acupuncture.
Alright.
There's no sun, so I don't know where your weak point is.
Sun!
What the fuck is that?
Okay.
Friend.
Where is this?
Okay, it's the head.
Who would've thought it's the head again?
Don't worry, Argyle.
Everything will be fine.
Wait, I think like it's like his toe.
Right?
His toe hurt.
Okay, let go of your toe so I can chew your toe.
Oh, unlucky.
Okay, maybe I'll use that bow.
Don't worry, I'm gonna shoot your toe.
Nine out of ten doctors recommend it.
How do I use this?
Okay.
Shoot toe.
Alright.
Lift up your toe.
Lift it up.
Wait, how do I shoot this?
Am I...
Am I stupid?
Oh, I just let go.
Okay, let go.
Yeah!
Come on!
Lift up your...
There we go.
Come on, lift it up!
Lift it up!
Stop lifting up this one!
Yeah.
Am I hitting it?
I don't even know.
Alright, lift it up again.
Okay, don't worry.
Slow and steady, we'll figure this out.
Oh, there you go!
See?
We did it!
Nice.
Alright.
Okay.
How do I climb up?
Alright.
Next second step.
Second step.
Oh!
Here!
Here, here!
Put away!
Put it away!
There we go.
Alright, it took me a while.
Alright, nice.
We figured it out.
Oh god, camera.
Oh god, camera!
Don't worry, sir!
I have a 100% success rate!
You'll be a new person by the time I'm done with you!
Don't worry!
People loved it!
We're gonna get rid of all that stress, sir!
Welcome to the Doki Massage Parlor!
Alright.
Can we do acupuncture and massage par- Oh!
Sir!
I know this is your first time, but I come highly recommended!
Do not worry!
Stop!
Don't worry!
Do not worry!
This is normal!
This is a normal amount of oil to drip out!
Hahaha!
Very normal amount!
Your headache is gonna be gone!
I swear!
I swear, sir!
Don't worry!
It's a hu- I would never lie to you!
Hahaha!
Getting that pore out!
You know?
Gotta clean those pores!
Wait, it's not glowing anymore.
Huh?
The fuck?
You're stressed out in more than one area?
Hahaha!
Sir, where else are you stressed?
I hate the target.
What the fu- Oh shit!
Hahaha!
Oh, I can't just drop down.
Sir, we need to find out where your second pore is.
You gotta let go, man!
You gotta take some breaks!
You're not- Unless you're a workaholic, then that's fine.
Is it your- your nips down there?
Is your nips down there...
hurty?
Hahaha!
Okay, we need to figure it out.
Where else is he hurty?
Where else?
Oh, god!
Oh shit!
Okay, okay!
Where is it?
Is it his butt?
Oh, it's his butt!
Oh, sir, don't worry!
Don't be embarrassed.
Sometimes, instead of the head, the stress can go to the ass.
And it's not like the flattering type, too.
So like, do not worry.
You are not the only one.
Don't be embarrassed.
You're not the first- You might be my second client!
So, this- You are the first client that I have that's stressed out on the ass.
So...
Sorry.
Hahaha!
Actually, you are my first- You are my second client.
So, in reality, you are my first client to be stressed out down there.
So... But don't be embarrassed!
I'm pretty sure many other- I will have many other clients that will be stressed out as well.
Do not worry.
I shall relieve you of the oil down there.
Where the fuck is it?
Hahaha!
Oh, there it is!
Okay.
There you go.
Woooo!
Stop!
Hahaha!
It's okay!
Your figure will not change!
Kind- Kind Colossus!
Do not worry!
Oh!
Please stop moving!
What- Stop moving or I'm gonna get the good parts of your ass!
There you go.
Alright.
One more hit.
And then... Boop!
Hahaha!
You're welcome!
Please make sure to leave a Yelp review and a Google review.
Yay!
Another happy customer!
Let's go, Argo!
Why can't I run?
Hahaha!
Shit!
I'm just running!
Hahaha!
Now he's so relaxed!
Look at him!
He's like lying on the ground!
So relaxed!
Hahaha!
He's free now!
Now, 100% success rate!
Alright.
Bring music back up and bring sound effects down just a little bit.
Oops!
I just saw that.
That was something.
I said 20 minutes ago.
Hahaha!
Yay!
Another happy customer!
0 out of 5.
Too much booty play!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
What is this?
The anger of the sleeping giant shatters the earth.
I'll make you cry.
Why are you so stressed out?
Yeah, it's just like...
Like those famous TikTok clips where they like...
They like poke holes into the head and then like all that oil drops out.
All the stress oil drops out.
It's just like that.
Okay, we need to boost that up and then turn on sound effects.
Alright, sound guy, let me know if that's okay.
Oh, this one's fun.
I'm getting better at the controls.
See you guys?
I've got... I conquered journalist mode.
Okay, but not the horse mode.
The horse mode is still...
I'm still having issues with that.
Hahaha!
I'm still having issues with the fucking...
The fucking horse.
Horse is so hard to ride.
Who would have thought?
Alright, pray time.
Pray.
Pray to save.
You guys said there's a salamander near the shrines?
Is there one near here?
Is there one near here, guys?
Okay, where the fuck is my sword telling me to go?
Sword.
Tell me the way.
Up?
Left?
Okay, left.
Not here.
Alright.
We're gonna figure this out.
Alright, let's go.
The third boss.
We're at a record!
Guys, we're already at number three.
You know, I had very low expectations for myself.
I honestly thought I would get like one boss throughout this entire run.
But now... this way.
Okay.
But now I got two.
That's already really, really good.
Okay.
That's really good for us.
Alright, now we just gotta figure out... Why are there no other people here in this world?
Where am I?
Where are the people though?
It's gonna be like across, I think.
Yeah, we've already exceeded expectations.
We've doubled our expectations.
I thought I'm gonna spend like two plus hours trying to find one guy.
In the end, in the end, we struggled with the controls at first, but we're getting better.
And we're...
We own a successful massage parlor.
Successful massage and acupuncture parlor.
And skin care.
We're acupuncture, skin care, massage.
All at one.
Nice.
This way.
Okay, it's this way.
Wait, what?
Is it underneath again?
Wait, am I in the wrong area?
No, right?
It says down there.
What?
No.
Okay, we'll go this way and try to see.
I have no idea if I'm in the wrong place.
I feel like...
What is it called?
Like when you... the oil stuff.
The oil treatment.
Is it also called...
There's no way that's also acupuncture, right?
Like it's actually like hardcore acupuncture.
Where like...
It's like... they literally drill a hole.
Is it bloodletting?
Is it actually bloodletting?
Oh my god.
Yeah, that's what I do.
I don't have a license for it because like...
I'm just naturally talented.
And like if you're naturally talented in these things, you don't need a license.
It's all word of mouth.
You know?
Okay, where do I go?
It's this way.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Where is it?
Am I in the wrong way?
Am I lost now?
Okay.
Oh, it's this way.
Okay, we gotta figure out how to get across.
Okay.
From here.
This is how you get across.
Oh yeah!
We have a map!
What the fuck is that skull?
Oh, that's where we killed the Colossus!
We have a map.
We're doing it.
We figured... Oh wait, is this a shrine?
This has to be a shrine.
Time to pray.
Pray to save.
Pray.
Boop.
Yay!
Is there a lizard?
A salamander?
What do they look like?
What does salamander...
Wait, is that salamander?
No, that's just grass.
What do they look like?
I don't...
I don't remember what they look like.
How tiny are they?
Are they big?
What do they look like?
Yeah, but like...
Are they big?
Are they small?
What...
What color?
White tail.
Oh yes.
Yes, the white tail on these white rocks.
So easy to find.
They can climb?
Who taught these lizards how to climb?
Okay.
Let's see.
Alright, I can climb too.
Little do they know.
I need to figure out.
Oh, I see him!
Hello buddy, I see you.
Bro, stop!
Okay, I see him.
Oh no, what can I grasp?
God damn it.
I need to figure out what I can climb.
Oh my god, please.
I don't even know what this guy's name is.
I know my horse name, but not him.
I see him!
I know what they look like now.
Oh my god.
Those little fucking pew pew pew sounds.
How do I climb up?
Oh, there it is.
I see you.
I see you up there.
Can't escape from me.
I need to find a way to get up there.
I need your stamina.
It's for my business.
I need to grow a healthy business.
Come on, I see you.
Boop!
Is that it?
Oh!
I thought you were dead!
Please, come back.
You always come back second, right?
Wait, what?
How is that not a hit?
Boop!
Are you dead?
Are you dead dead?
Okay, double tap.
Just to be sure.
There you go.
Is it stuck in the wall?
I swear, are you stuck in the wall?
Are you...
Are you stu-
How do I get...
How do I get it?
Oh, thank god!
Okay!
I thought he was actually stuck in the wall.
I...
I'm gonna be so fucking sad.
I got it.
Guys, it's okay.
He was not stuck in the wall.
Okay, nice.
We got the stamina.
I should be okay.
Yay!
I was not okay.
It's okay, pray.
Pray to save.
Nice.
We're fine.
I don't know.
I thought... I thought I would just...
I thought I would just walk over it and...
And like...
The lizard is... The lizard tail is just gonna disappear.
Like, underneath my feet.
Because I picked it up.
It has to be here.
Oops.
It's nice to know I have unlimited arrows.
It has to be here.
There's like a really weird...
tunnel here.
So where else would the giant be?
Alright, look.
I got spoiled by...
modern games, okay?
Modern games today...
They fucking feed you from the bottom.
Because they're scared we're gonna hurt ourselves.
Which is very true.
Modern games today...
They don't want us to hurt ourselves.
So like...
I'm not used to...
having to figure this out myself.
Like, y'all...
Because they're scared!
They're scared if like...
you're frustrated at a game, you won't play anymore.
Because it's too hard.
Because I've done that as a child.
They're scared.
And it's understandable.
Alright, nice.
This has to be a lake, right?
Are we there?
Did I fuck up?
Did I go the wrong way?
Where's the sun?
Where the fuck is the sun?
Sun, shine on my sword so I know where to go.
Sun!
Okay.
Sun.
Alright.
Sun says...
Where does the sun say?
Where?
Sun, where do I...
Oh, here.
Here!
Okay, this way.
We're good.
We're good, it's this way.
Okay.
I ran past a lizard?
Oh no, that's not good.
Was it in the little tiny cavern?
Was it in here?
The little tiny cavern here?
Praise the sun.
Lizard?
Lizard, where are you?
I need to eat your tail!
For stamina!
Okay.
Don't worry, I can hear.
I can hear his little feet.
I have my fucking bow.
Where's your little feet?
Where are you?
Where are you, lizard?
Please.
I'm gonna eat your tail.
It apparently helps my stamina.
Oh, is that the lizard?
No, that's just a rock.
Where the fuck is it?
What?
Argo, please!
Stop!
I'm trying to find the lizard!
He's right there.
No, there, Doki.
Doki, it's there.
Oh, god.
Boop.
Wait, where did he go?
Where did his body go?
Where did...
Where did his butt...
Wait.
Oh, that's the tail!
Is that the tail?
Is that his body?
Is that it?
Oh, thank god.
Why did he, like, sink into the rock?
It, like, slipped in.
Okay.
Does that mean there's a white one?
Only shrine lizards?
Are you kidding me?
Then what the fuck was the point of eating the normal lizard?
Am I just a freak?
Can't believe you guys made me go back.
I can't believe you guys made me go back.
Argo, come over here.
I can't run properly.
What's wrong with him?
What's...
Ever since I ate that lizard, I haven't been able to run right, chat.
I...
It messed me up.
My legs...
My legs aren't doing so well.
Argo!
Argo, come on!
Where are you?
Come on!
You're over here.
I know you're faster than me.
Stop pretending.
Nice.
Alright.
We gotta go kill the third colossal.
I mean...
We gotta go...
to another appointment.
We got a new client, Argo.
They're mega fucking stressed right now.
I told you having client base via word of mouth was a good idea.
We don't have to waste money with stupid advertising.
As long as we make one client really, really, really happy...
we'll never have to advertise our services.
Let's go.
It has to be like...
here.
Okay.
We're getting better.
This way?
Is there more ways to go?
Oh, which way?
Oh no.
Oh...
Wait.
It splits.
Oh no.
Okay.
I've always been not so lucky.
So...
Maybe this way?
I mean, look!
It's like...
There's like a...
creepy shrine.
It has to be the right way, right?
There's like shrines and stuff here.
Is the sun up?
The sun is up.
Okay.
Where is it telling me to go?
Backwards.
Alright.
I went the wrong way.
Wait.
Is there a shrine?
Is there a shrine here?
Is this like the shrine palace?
I can't tell.
It's fine.
Is that... Is that a save station?
I can't tell.
There's so many...
All the rocks look the same.
Wait.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Pray the save.
It's time to pray.
Boop.
Yay!
Nice.
Oh, this looks like a really fancy one.
There has to be a salamander here.
Why do you see you?
I fucking see you.
Okay.
Shh.
Nice.
Here we go.
No.
There we go.
Yeah.
He has to be dead.
He's definitely dead.
But just to be sure.
Nice.
Alright.
We got another one.
Boop.
More stamina.
We're getting stronger.
Our clients are gonna love this.
Wait.
Where's my horse?
What happens if I...
Oh!
Fuck!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
You...
You wasn't...
I
just wanted to know if I'll clip through you.
It was a joke!
I would never argue...
You know I would never do that to you.
Alright.
I'm just training him.
Guys, I'm just training my horse.
He has to learn how to dodge...
Dodge arrows.
Okay.
Save the prey.
Alright.
Argo, come on.
Come on.
I know you're hungry.
We're all hungry here.
We gotta save the princess.
Guys!
It's all about like...
Our horses need a train too!
You know?
Like what if arrows shoot him?
He's now more prepared.
Penguin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He's now more prepared for like warfare.
Okay.
This way.
Alright, Argo.
Let's go.
This has to be the right way, right?
Oh my god.
That's not the sword.
The fuck is my sword?
No.
This way?
God, this is such a big area.
Maybe here?
Maybe to the right?
Don't worry.
There's a sun right here that's gonna show me the way.
The sun right here.
Okay.
No.
Argo, please.
This one patch of sun will tell me where to go.
This way?
How the fuck do I...
How do I get there?
Where am I?
Surely, I'm gonna figure it out.
I'm gonna figure this out, guys.
Claat!
There's no way I can climb this.
There has to be...
Okay.
Argo, you must know where to go.
There's no way you climb the mountain.
I don't have enough stamina for that.
There's no fucking way.
Is it here?
Is this water?
No, this is a desert.
This is a desert?
How the fuck do I...
How do I get so lost?
Oh God!
I didn't know...
What's the fun?
Is this where the boss is?
Why would there be an open patch of area?
It's the opposite of water.
Water.
Oh no!
Yellow and blue look the same!
Okay, water might be like... oh there must be water over there.
I think I got it.
I think I'm on the right patch.
It's like the biggest beach.
You're right.
It's like a beach!
Guys, I think I'm at the beach, chat.
Eventually the sand will become water.
That's how beaches work.
That's how beaches work!
The sand turns into water!
Where else do you think water comes from?
Okay.
I'm almost there!
See?
It's like somewhere here!
Where am I?
Okay, as soon as we find the water, we're good.
Don't worry guys.
Every sand eventually connects to water.
That's just basic geology.
The stadium, the sun...
There has to be water somewhere.
There's no way.
Oh god!
Don't worry, Argo!
Okay, here.
There has to be water somewhere There!
See?!
There's water!
I f***ing knew it!
I knew it!
I knew there was water...
None of you believed me!
I knew there was water.
See?
Water is like right here!
Look!
There's water down here!
See?
Water!
I told you.
Eventually you reach water.
Now where do I go?
I ran into a giant circle!
I told you there was no way to go!
I actually...
I ran into a huge circle!
Oh my god!
Back into the cavern I go!
Back into this tunnel I go!
Oh my god!
Surely this is the right way!
Maybe this time... I can't get lost this time.
I'm going one way.
There's no way I can get lost.
This is literally like one direction.
Oh god!
I'm so sorry!
You have a really stupid person as the writer.
Please!
Okay, here we go.
We're good!
We did it!
Eventually we will find the area.
We made it!
We did it, Arco!
We fucking did it!
Can you go in the water?
Oh my god, you can swim!
My horse can do anything.
Please.
Go deeper into the water.
Oh no, is this like a water level?
Okay guys, I don't think Arco likes the water.
But I... Do I like the water?
Okay, I'm fine with the water too.
Alright.
I can dive?
Oh, I don't like that.
I do not like that fact that I can swim like this.
Can I swim faster?
Or I'm gonna be like super fucking slow forever.
Alright.
Watch my stamina.
My stamina is okay.
I don't know if I can like swim faster.
Oh, I swim faster if I'm diving?
Okay.
That's good to know.
I don't know what happened.
Ever since I ate that one lizard, I'm super fucking janked up.
Like...
I don't feel so good.
He's super janked up right now.
Where do I go?
Do I just...
In here?
Okay.
Oh shit.
Okay, wait.
I must be able to grab this, right?
Oh.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Okay.
I thought I was gonna die.
And then... cause I don't know how to find this place again.
I don't...
I'm gonna be like, please.
Do not make me...
I'm just gonna be like, please.
I really don't want to fucking try to find this area again.
Okay, apparently if I dive down...
If I dive down...
I'm gonna be like, get there faster.
But it's okay.
I just need to go back up.
Oh god.
There's no shrine nearby?
There must be a shrine nearby.
But like, I'm already too...
I'm already too far in.
Alright.
I can do this.
I just need to make sure I don't fucking fall off.
Oh, why are you so janked up, man?
Here's some yellow paint.
Thank you for your very first Super Chat Admiral.
Thank you.
Thank you for the yellow paint.
I really appreciate it.
Okay, we need to figure out how to climb this.
I wonder if I can...
I must be able to...
Okay.
Maybe...
Okay, no.
Wait, why can't I grab this?
Can I grab this?
Alright.
No!
The fucking...
Okay.
Alright, we're good.
We can do this.
Thank you for the...
Give the ship.
Thank you.
Where's the stairs?
Where the fuck is the stairs?
No, I figured it out!
I just...
I looked at the wrong way!
Guys...
Guys, is there a yellow paint mod in this game?
No!
What do you mean?
No, no, no.
It was like...
It was the wrong button.
I accidentally pressed the wrong button in chat.
I'm not that stupid.
Guys...
I'm not...
Guys!
I swear I'm not that stupid.
I accidentally pressed the wrong button in chat.
I...
I like pressed the wrong button.
And I knew where...
I knew what to do!
I swear!
Okay.
This is it.
This time.
I was just trying to teach you guys what not to do.
I was trying to teach you guys what not to do in this game.
Because I know a lot of people, this is like their first time playing.
So they don't know, like, the basics.
So like, that's what I'm here for.
I'm like, guys, don't do this.
Remember?
Guys...
I told you.
Don't...
Don't do that.
Guys...
I told you!
It's a great lesson to learn!
To not do!
I told you guys!
It's a...
I'm trying to show you guys all the examples of the wrong things to do, chat.
You're welcome.
Alright, alright, alright.
So now that you know all the things you shouldn't do...
Here is what the actual answer was.
Alright, here we go.
The answer might surprise you.
Don't worry.
The answer is going to surprise all of you.
It's going to be crazy.
It's going to be fucking crazy.
Alright, so what you do is...
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Woo!
Alright.
And then...
You...
You do that.
Yes!
Oh fuck, I'm so smart!
Okay, and then...
There we go.
See?
I told you.
The answer will surprise you.
We did it.
Yay.
Alright, my new client.
Here he comes.
Here's my new client.
Word of mouth.
Look at that.
He woke up from a really bad headache.
But don't worry, sir.
I'll give you the Doki Bird experience.
To help you relieve that stress.
He just woke up.
He's a little angy.
But do not worry.
Where is your weak point?
Not your head.
Your belly button?
Why is your stress in your belly button?
Sir.
Sir, why are you stressed out in the belly?
Did you have a tummy...
Does your tummy hurt?
Sir?
Sir!
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh shit!
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Where is his weak point?
I can't tell.
His tummy hurt.
Where is his weak point at?
I don't know.
Sir, I know your tummy hurt.
You gotta let...
You gotta be careful what you eat.
Oh, what the...
How does that hurt me?
It's just rock!
Sir, I need you to...
Sir, I need you to fucking throw your sword down.
Okay.
Sir!
Sir, the longer you delay this...
The more I charge you!
I work...
I work $60 an hour!
Sir!
This is a $60 an hour experience!
Throw down the sword!
Maybe that's why it hurts.
Only si...
Alright, nice.
He's throwing it down.
Nice.
Alright, how do I climb the sword?
How the fuck do I climb...?
What?
No, it's at the backside?
Oh my god.
Oh, it was at the backside.
Guys, you're getting really dumb.
Look, I gotta start my clientele!
I'm fucking jacked.
Thank you for the potential, super.
Oh, I can bring the music up.
Okay.
Guys, I'm just starting out.
Oh!
I'm literally... I invest zero dollars in advertising.
It's just by word of mouth.
This is only my third client.
I'm trying to figure out how to climb the fucking sword.
Alright, here we go.
Knock it to the ground?
The armor seems brittle?
Oh shit, is it?
Bro, I don't know.
Thank you.
Thank you for...
Okay.
Don't worry.
Apparently his armor is brittle.
Eventually this puny arrow is gonna do something.
Oh fuck!
Okay.
How to climb?
There's something to climb!
I'm just gonna...
Fuck you!
Even died.
Just fast eating.
Woo!
Trying to figure out where to climb.
But I can't find it.
Oh!
I'm sinking!
Maybe I can climb you.
No.
No no no no no no no no no!
Okay, maybe I can climb this.
No?
I know!
God, I know!
God!
God, I'm sinking!
I'm sinking, God!
Okay.
God, please.
Please, you have to be more direct with me.
Wait.
No, please.
Swing your sword.
Swing your sword again.
Let me cook.
Look.
Oh!
Oh, I figured it out!
I know!
I know what to do!
Swing that sword!
I can't believe God is backseeing me.
God, please.
I know.
I know this is frustrating to watch.
God.
I swear I am trying.
He just let go his...
No!
That was it!
I was too slow!
Please!
Please again!
He's doing it.
What?
Oh, I did it!
That's what the circle was for!
Oh my God!
I fucking did it!
Okay.
I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
I broke his armor!
Oh shit!
Guys, I think... Guys, I am not okay.
Guys, I was not okay.
Guys, I don't know.
God.
I think God saved me there.
Oh God.
Okay.
This is it.
I figured it out.
Oh God.
After
20 years!
God, I did it!
I climbed!
Holy shit.
Doki did it.
No!
Clean fucking holding!
What is wrong with you?
Where am I teleporting to?
Okay.
Bro!
Climb up this fucking... Bro!
I swear to God, kid!
Kid, I swear to fucking God!
Bro, this fucking kid, man.
Okay, we need to get to the tummy.
Because his tummy hurt.
Wait.
Okay.
His tummy hurt.
We need to fucking head to the tummy.
It's the tummy, right?
Or can I stab the head?
No, it's his tummy.
Okay.
Okay, kid.
Tummy time.
Oh God.
Oh, fucking hell.
Alright, there we go.
There's his tummy.
Don't worry!
The Doki experience!
We will let out all that stress!
Ha!
There we go.
No!
Don't worry!
Oh my God!
No wonder your tummy hurt!
Look at all the stress!
Don't worry, Sam!
You will be a happy cl... It looks like a dog with, like, boxing gloves.
You look at it close enough.
Oh no.
Oh no!
Oh, we're just gonna rest here for a little bit.
I think we're fine.
Okay.
You look hard enough.
It does look like a dog with boxing gloves on.
Oh God.
Okay.
Don't worry.
We're just gonna rest a little bit.
And then...
Okay.
And then stop!
No!
Come on!
Just need to do one step!
Bro!
Let me fucking...
Boop!
There we go.
A little tiny poke.
I'm gonna rest here now.
And then... Oh no.
Jumping is so scary.
One more.
Boop!
Is that it?
Is it just your tummy?
Is there anywhere else?
Just your little tummy?
Oh no.
Now it has to be the head.
The head is always, like, the last spot.
Okay.
Up I go.
Up I go!
How do I get up?
How do I get up without having to worry?
How do I...
How do I get up from here?
From up the fucking... back?
Oh no.
From the arm?
Oh maybe.
Okay, do you think I can make it?
Alright, alright.
Please stop swinging, sir!
The longer it is, the more you have to charge!
Sir!
I do not feel very good charging you such a high bill, but I will if I have to!
Okay, there we go.
Where am I?
I am here.
Alright.
Don't worry, just resting a little bit.
Boop!
Okay.
Climb.
Keep climbing.
There we go.
We are fine.
We are okay.
I climb.
I climb!
Oh god.
My stamina though.
It's fine.
The hell, Vang jumped!
Oh!
Don't worry.
This is the DokiBur special.
Every client requests for it.
You will be fine!
It's just the stress oil.
Nothing to worry about.
I did not poke.
I have so much experience with this.
You don't have to worry, sir.
I did not...
I did not hit any vital...
Vital nerves!
Your brain is okay!
Your brain...
Let's open the seventh chakra right now.
Just a simple scalp massage.
Nine out of ten.
Ten doctors recommend to cure your headache.
And now he doesn't suffer anymore.
Now he doesn't have any more headaches.
It's just a bad blood coming out.
Guys, it's just a bad blood.
Nice!
Another Google review.
Another happy client.
I hope they keep recommending me to future clients.
Yeah.
Yayy!
No more tummy hurt.
Look at that!
Look at all these Google reviews.
Now I can put my bed over there.
Another happy land.
Yeah!
Every single...
Pac...
Exactly!
Somebody understands!
I'm so good at this.
You're too good at this?
No, they'll come back, right?
They'll come back for more...
Happy landing!
They land on the ground out of happiness.
Fearful it is not.
I mean, to be fair, it's called Colossus.
So, aren't they technically all giants?
100% satisfaction guarantee.
Exactly!
Yay!
Bro, I don't think I'm gonna out-jank this guy.
This kid is gonna be forever fucked up.
Holy shit!
He's so fucked up.
A cat in the way!
We just live like this now.
Ever since we ate that bad...
The bad lizard.
This way.
This way?
Where is this way?
I guess it's this way.
Ever since we ate that bad lizard...
Life has not been the same.
Come on!
Are you still mad at me that I shot the arrow?
You know you need more training with the arrow stuff.
It's not my fault.
Harlow.
Alright, here you go.
Yeah, no one ever complains.
Because everyone had a good time.
This is this way.
This is the way.
No, if he...
Okay, no, actually horses can hold grudges.
Like, they actually can fuck you up if they hate you.
That's why you never stand behind a horse.
Because they can actually mess you up.
You can actually break your back if the horse does not like you.
But, good thing for me...
Ida loves me.
He loves me.
Because I've always been like, so nice to him.
Oh god, I do not like this area.
It looks so fucking...
It looks...
I'm just training him to be a better horse.
Chat?
He needs to be prepared.
For the real shit.
Where am I?
Is it a turtle?
Is this a turtle giant?
Wait, I remember this!
Wait, I remember this...
Turtle giant.
Jump.
Jump, Arlo.
What, are you scared?
Okay, yeah, that's...
Actually, I just realized you cannot jump that.
Okay, wait, but I can.
Can I jump that?
I'm not scared.
Speedrun.
There you go.
You see, I'm fine.
So smart.
See?
I don't need a journalist difficulty.
I just figured it out myself.
Now, where do I go?
Oh,
this way.
Alright.
This way.
I'm speedrunning.
Look at that.
Three bosses down.
No, it's Ikea he...
I still can't believe that actually happened.
I can't believe Ikea actually saw that.
Ikea actually sold, like...
Like, what the...
How did that happen?
That is such a fucking oversight.
Oh shit.
You made it?
How?
How did you get here?
Have you guys never heard?
In Ikea.
Like, it was a long time ago.
But Ikea, accidentally, quote-unquote, sold horse meatballs.
I'm a horse.
And then people found out.
We're like, what?
We've been eating horse meat this entire time?
Yeah!
Now we're... yeah, and then we found out.
And then they're like, oh that was an accident.
And then so like, you know, we don't eat horse meatballs anymore!
Wait, is it this guy?
That has to be the giant, right?
That has to be him.
Well, I don't have the sun, so I have to figure out if it's this guy that... or in the cave I go.
This is a little oopsie.
That has to be a colossus.
Like, look at him.
Oh my god, it's like a Komodo dragon.
New customer!
Oh my god, did Arlo recommend you?
Okay, where's your spot?
Head?
Oh, it's the head.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
What do I do?
Do I shoot you in the stomach?
Can I grasp you tightly?
No.
I'll distract him!
He likes horses!
Don't worry, I'm gonna shoot him in the butt.
Look.
See?
He kills one of them by just doing that.
That means...
Imagine if I just... this entire stream, I just do this.
This is the entire stream.
Okay, the environment.
Why am I limping?
Why are you limping?
Let's see.
How do I use the environment against you?
How do I...
Do I go here?
There is a tunnel down there.
Where is it?
What's the tunnels anyway?
Go into the cave?
Yeah, I was like wondering what the cave was for.
Alright.
I'll be right back!
I gotta get some extra materials, sir!
Don't worry!
Wait, there's another way.
Oh no.
There's two pathways.
Oh, cuz there's multiple cave entrances!
Wait, what?
Sorry, what?
Now I'm here.
Wait, wait!
My head?
It's turning?
I got it.
I figured it out.
I know what to do.
Hello, I am here now.
Hello.
I'm gonna poke you in the ass.
Come on.
Stop looking at my horse!
Come on!
I'm right here!
Don't you see me?
I don't think he likes that.
He does not like that.
Down here!
Arlo!
Stop baiting the horse!
Turn around!
I'm right here!
Alright.
We gotta make sure the fucking giant horse knows I'm here.
I think he fell in love with my horse.
I'm right here, asshole!
That's fucking right.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
You see me?
That's fucking right!
I'm right here!
I'm here!
I don't know if that worked!
Alright, that must have worked, right?
He must have seen me yawning in the caves.
Does he know?
I'm right here!
Come down!
Fight me like a real horse!
I'm literally right here!
Oh, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah!
Alright, no more horsing around!
Alright.
You see the Colossus to reach his back.
Okay.
Thank you, God.
Thank you for the backseating.
I really appreciate it.
Wait, where did he go?
Bro, what the fuck?
He just gave up!
He just... he just gave up on me!
Horse!
I'm not just a mosquito!
I am your therapist!
And I can see you're so fucking tensed up right now.
Look at you!
You're so tensed!
You're so lucky your friends recommended me to take care of you.
Oh my God.
Where's the other way to the cave?
He's looking, he's looking.
He's casually looking at me now.
Turn around!
I'm trying my best, guys!
Hehehehehehe!
Ok...
Hahaha!
God, I am trying my best, but he's too smart to be deceived.
Bro, he just doesn't care!
He doesn't fucking care what I do!
Sir, you're being charged for every hour!
Sir!
My rate has now increased to $80 an hour, sir!
Turn around!
Bro, but look at the damage though.
Guys, look at...
Look at all that damage I did.
That one speck of damage.
Stop, dude.
Guys, it's called acupuncture.
Come over here.
I charge... I got better with experience, so I can charge $80 now.
I got better at my job.
I'm right here.
I'm right here, horse.
Turn around.
Arlo, please.
Please, Arlo.
This is between me and the fucking other horse.
I know you're jealous!
But me and this horse...
We gotta settle something here.
Alright.
You see me?
Do you see me?
Yeah, right?
You see me, right?
Oh, fuck.
I think he knows now.
I think he understands.
Oh, God.
Oh, he definitely understands.
He definitely understands.
Alright.
He understands now.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Why am I so jink?
Please.
Please don't turn around.
I am trying so hard to deceive him!
But he doesn't care!
He doesn't!
What did I do?
Okay.
I got it.
Wait.
I deceived him.
I got it.
Oh, my God.
What did I do from here?
Do I just...
Do I just climb?
Oh, shit.
Tail!
Grab the tail!
Board!
He got Board!
He is the head.
Oh, it's the brains!
Okay.
I can't figure it out.
Guys, okay, he knows.
Okay, I'm right here.
I'm right here.
Come over here.
I realized it was the brakes.
I thought it was supposed to be the tail.
Alright.
You just don't pull somebody's hair, okay?
It's like so rude.
It's so rude to pull people's hairs.
So like I was just trying to be like...
polite.
You know?
It's okay to pull the tail but not the hair.
Alright, this time.
This time he knows.
He knows, right?
I'm right here.
Okay, now he knows.
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Please, kid.
We're gonna kill...
We're gonna kill this boss.
The tail is part of the treatment.
The hair is always a no-go.
People don't like it when you touch the hair.
Okay.
There you go.
I'm here.
Don't worry.
It's...
I'm coming back here.
Lower your head.
Come on.
Nice.
Grab it.
No!
That was awkward.
Alright.
I didn't know how...
How fucking short I jumped!
This time!
He's still there!
He doesn't notice!
It's okay.
This time.
He's gonna...
This time, this time, this time.
There's no way he saw me this time.
Alright, lower, lower.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
That's good.
Just stay there.
Yes!
I did it!
I told you.
You just gotta believe.
You just... please.
You just gotta... Don't worry!
The treatment is here!
Okay.
Don't worry.
I've never done it with a horse before.
But like, it's a head.
Brains are the same.
The head should be the same.
It has a skull in there.
It has a skull!
And pointy things go in skull!
Here we go.
Alright.
Don't worry.
We're fine.
Stab.
It's fine.
There's not a lot of blood.
Like human blood.
But that is okay.
It's okay.
It can't be much different.
Please stop moving!
Okay.
Maybe if I just stay here in it right now.
Alright.
Woah!
Sir!
I'm not done with the treatment!
I should... Woah!
Shit!
Okay.
We gotta be able to grab this for now.
And then I can like chill a little bit and recharge my stuff.
Woah!
No!
Grab on!
You have to keep grabbing on!
Oh god.
He's moving so much.
It's so hard.
Woah!
That's okay.
It's fine.
No!
Oh god.
This is so difficult.
Okay.
Just gonna recharge it here.
He's chill.
I'm like a little like head fly.
I'm like those like little birds that just stand on the head of like some fucking lion.
They're just like whatever.
That's okay.
You don't need to see the stamina.
Everything is okay.
Hehehe.
As long... As long as it's working.
Hold your horses.
Woo!
So we're just recharging it little by little and then...
Stop!
Eehaw.
God.
You're so fucking stressed.
Is that Martha?
Are you and the kids alright?
Did she take the kids?
Sir.
I don't think therapy can... I don't think... I don't think massage...
No!
Oh hey, there's this.
Might as well stab this too.
I mean, it's here.
So I might as well.
It's just like a little bonus area too.
Oh nice, he's less stressed.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
How did you wake up?
Oh no.
Bro...
Look, I think you need more than just massages, man.
I know like...
You have some extra spending money now that you don't have to have to worry about like Martha and the kids.
But bro...
You gotta get... You gotta like actually go to therapy, man.
Massages aren't therapy.
Oh shit.
He's stressed.
Oh no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I can relax a little bit.
I can relax a little bit here.
Alright.
But holy shit, look at all these pent up blood.
Don't worry.
The best I can do is make you forget...
Just a little bit.
Alright?
You're just a few more stabs.
What do you mean?
His child support payments are colossal.
Now he's relaxed forever.
I'm not licensed or anything.
But I don't need to be licensed.
I'm just that talented.
Yay.
So look, now he doesn't have to worry about the kids for today.
I just did it.
Yay!
I leveled up!
Now I charge a hundred dollars an hour.
Another 10 out of 10 review.
Dracula, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I'm so good at my job.
Oh my god!
So many Google reviews.
If you're good at your job, you don't need a license.
I fixed depression.
10 out of 10, my wife left me.
That's a good thing.
And then...
and then for some reason, there were more IKEA meatballs after that.
Arlo, what are you doing?
Are you looking at my girlfriend for it?
10 out of 10!
Pass the colossus shadow across a misty lake.
Oh, is this a fish, Colossus?
Is this a... I fucking was playing for two hours?!
Okay, this game fucking makes time pass by so fast.
This does not feel like two hours.
I did not feel like I was playing for two hours!
Holy shit.
Damn.
That means I've only...
Okay, gotta pray.
Pray to save!
Pray.
Alright.
Where do we go?
Sword, tell me where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go, Sword?
Where is it telling me?
What?
This way?
I have to go to the lake.
Here.
Okay.
Alright, Arlo.
Arlo, come over here.
I need to go to a lake now.
I'm doing good progress.
I got like four clients so far.
Will you guys let me drill a hole into your head to let out your stress?
For like a hundred dollars an hour?
Sure.
Why not?
It is like a fucking deal!
A good bargain, chat.
It is actually like a hundred percent an absolute steal.
Guys, but what about the stress blood?
The stress oil?
Think about the stress oil!
Chat.
You wanna be stressed forever?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Hehehehehehe.
Guys, I am literally a professional!
He's this way.
I am a professional too, chat!
Your head is in good hands.
That's actually...
Like, look at all my happy clients!
Guys.
God, where are we?
Arlo, please.
Wait, where do I go?
Did I walk the wrong way?
You have come...
Like, I literally...
Okay.
Alright.
Like, these... my clients were so fucking relaxed...
That they like...
They left... they like... started surrounding me after I...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Hehehehehehe.
They were so relaxed that they visit me when I am asleep.
That's how good of a client I am.
Alright.
That's how good of a fucking...
Uh...
Massage therapist I am.
Let's see.
It has to be like here.
Right?
Well, I don't have the sun anymore to help me.
So, I assume it is.
I assume it's like in this area.
Yeah, they entered a deep sleep.
They've never been as relaxed as I...
As I've made them.
Hehehehehehe.
Oh, is that shrine?
Oh, I have to dive, right?
I have to dive down here?
I have to swim down here.
Yeah.
Booooom.
It's not eternal sleep.
It's just sleep sleep.
That's different.
Is it this way?
Can't tell.
The sword was gone.
I hope I'm going the right way.
Where am I?
Hahahahaha.
I...
I hope...
I hope I'm going the right way.
One fear.
The fuck?
How do I...
I'm strapped.
I'm so trapped.
Where do I go?
Oh!
A cloud.
Okay.
Climb time.
Climb.
Alright, let's see if the colossus is here.
Is it here?
God hasn't told me anything yet...
God?
Am I...
Am I at the right area?
Are you?
I am!
Thank you, God!
I knew it.
Thank you, God, for telling me where to go.
Oh, it's a bird!
It's a bird colossus.
God, it's tired of me.
Hello, God.
Oh, he's so cool.
I love the design.
The design's really pretty.
Wait, this one's difficult?
No.
What do I do?
Can I die?
No, I'm okay.
Alright, I think I have to go somewhere, right?
Don't worry.
I do not swim very fast.
Give me a sec.
I am trying my best.
Yeah, it reminds me of the...
the crow Pokemon.
In, uh...
Yeah, it reminds me of the crow Pokemon.
Alright.
Don't worry, crow.
Don't worry.
I haven't massaged your crow before.
But I think it's the same anatomy as a person.
It can't be that different.
A head is a head.
There's a brain.
Did you see me?
I'm friendly!
The horse sent me!
Diesel's still alive!
He's still alive!
I'm friendly!
What's your weak point?
Head?
I assume it's the head.
Okay, let's see...
Ooh, the music is really nice though.
Alright, let's see... I'm gonna have to swim over- I don't know how to swim to him or something.
It's like there's so many...
There's so many pillars.
Do I swim to him?
Alright, I'm gonna say hi!
Don't do anything dumb!
Hey!
Hello bird!
I'm friendly!
I'm so friendly!
All your friends like me!
I'm just here to give you a nice massage!
And some acupuncture!
And like letting some extra stress oil out of your head!
Oh, okay.
Don't worry.
I'm in the water.
I can't...
Give me a secro!
I need to go back onto the wall!
Oh my god.
I feel like I'm fucking drowning.
Like the way he fucking swims, it looks like I'm actually drowning.
Thank you, God.
I can always count on you to backseat me, God.
Alright.
Crew!
You see me?
Yes, me!
Are we gonna be okay?
Woah!
Nice.
Oh, not nice!
Not nice!
God!
What do I do?
Oh, God.
What the fuck?
I can't climb that.
Oh, no.
Come on!
Come on, kid!
Kid!
Climb up!
Okay, there we go.
Thank fucking God.
Kid, please.
For the love of God, just get on his back.
I need a recharge.
Kid, you're not... you're not getting younger!
Your stamina is lowering!
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
Oh!
Get me down!
I didn't mean to do that.
Where the fuck is your weak point?
Oh, God.
Where is it?
Where is it pointing to?
Oh, it's on the wing!
It's the wing!
It's the left wing!
I figured it out!
Okay.
Just run.
Just fucking run!
Okay.
We're fine.
Oh, please.
Please, just grab onto it.
He has to glide.
He has to glide one time.
Alright.
Nice.
We're just gonna run.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
You're putting too much stress on the wing!
You're putting way too much stress on the wing!
Stop!
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Okay.
I should not have given it a little poke.
The poke might have been too tiny.
Oh, no!
Come on!
Yes!
Alright.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Turn around!
Woo!
What?
No!
He fucking pushed me off.
I'm so sad.
He pushed me off.
He has to fly back to me, right?
Come on!
Maybe I can, like...
If he'll fly back, right?
Bird, come back!
Come on, birdie!
Come on!
Just...
I'm just here to give you some therapy.
You know the drill!
He's just looking at me.
Oh, okay.
You gonna...
You gonna be okay?
Look, man.
You're really fucking tense, bro.
Oh.
Yes!
I grabbed it.
Can I go up?
Okay.
Alright, he's coming over.
Alright.
Nice.
I need to make sure...
Oh!
Alright.
Stop.
Please.
We have to be centered.
We have to be...
You need to relax!
When was the last time you stopped flying?
You know, birds don't have...
Wait.
There's no stress point here.
No!
Why did I jump?
I...
I don't know why I jumped.
That was an accident.
That was a little oopsie.
There was no stress point!
Where was it?
Okay.
I was so confused!
Oh, you need the sword out?
I'm so...
Oh my god.
Why can't I just like fucking poke it with my arrow?
It's the same thing.
It's both pointy.
It's literally the same thing.
Both pointy.
You see me?
I know you see me.
You can't ignore me forever.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Okay, let me go to the other one.
Let me...
Let me go...
Alright, there you go.
You have to come back, right?
There we go.
Alright.
Why can't I...
Why can't I have a magic bow too?
God bless my bow!
God, I need you to bless my other weapon.
This is not fair.
This is not fair!
Alright, I need you to come back.
I need...
I need you to come back, sir.
Sir.
You're not gonna like the bell when I send it to you.
Look, even if you don't like this treatment, it is for the sake of longevity.
It's so you can live longer.
Don't you wanna live longer?
All that stress is not good for your heart.
Why do you have a heart attack while flying?
What do you do?
Okay, let's...
Poke him.
Gotta poke him.
Alright.
Got my sword.
Bird, come down.
Bird!
There's no fucking...
There's no bargains for this.
Oh shit!
XFL.
Where did he go?
Bird!
Am I on the wrong platform?
No.
This is the right one.
This is it.
Come down.
I know you wanna do this.
That's right.
There's no coupon code!
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
I need to fucking head over to the...
God.
Dude, this...
Why is this so difficult?
Oh no.
I don't like this.
Okay.
Alright.
Come on.
No!
I keep getting greedy!
I'm going for the tail.
Fuck this.
No.
Hold on to it!
You have buff arms!
There you go.
I gave up.
I'm gonna go for the wing.
I'm not gonna risk it.
There you go.
Nice!
Oh, thank God!
Okay.
Oh my God.
Look at all the stress oil.
You're gonna thank me later!
Flying is gonna be so easy after I'm done!
Trust!
Oh God.
No!
Oh!
Please!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Let me back up!
Just let me fucking...
Oh God.
No!
Please be...
Please be water!
Okay.
It's water.
Yeah, it's the stress oil.
You know like when you squeeze your face and all the oil comes out?
Yeah.
That's what I'm doing right now.
I'm just squeezing really, really hard.
That's what I'm doing.
Alright.
Where is he?
Where the fuck is he?
Wait, where did he go?
He disappeared.
I actually don't know where he is.
Where the fuck is the...
Oh, there he is.
Bird.
Get down here.
Please.
You have too many wings.
I have two.
Bird, please!
Please!
I know you see me.
Your eyes are red.
I know you acknowledge my existence.
That's right.
Okay.
Here we go.
And...
Jump!
There you go.
I hate that I grab onto it first and I don't move.
That shit is so frustrating.
Oh my god.
He is like the most frustrating boss!
He's actually so frustrating.
Oh my god.
Please.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Another hit.
Alright, just doing a little barrel roll.
But we're okay.
We're fine.
There's no more stress.
Look, see?
You're less stressed now!
You're less STRONG!
We're going to the back of the wing.
We're going to the back of the wing now.
I'd rather deal with the wing stress here.
Oh god.
Please go up.
Alright.
Oh my god!
Look at all the stress points!
Don't worry.
Dr. Doki is here.
The doctor is my first name.
It's not the medical time of doctor.
That's just my first name.
Okay.
Thank fucking god.
Oh, I shouldn't have...
I shouldn't just do the little pokes.
I should actually hold my sword up.
Oh no.
One more wing.
No!
Okay, we're fine.
We're just balancing ourselves.
We're fighting against the wind here.
Dr. Doki.
My first name is doctor.
My middle name is professor.
And then...
My last name is Doki.
So...
So I'm Dr. Professor Doki.
So I'm almost licensed.
You know?
It's almost like being licensed.
Because it's like recognized by the government.
God, please.
Please!
Show me the other wing!
Show me the other wing right now.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Stop!
Oh god, this one was so close.
That's the hardest.
Paging Dr. Professor Doki.
I show you my wing.
Please respond.
Yay!
Licensed upgrade.
Now I charge $150 an hour.
I'm getting like...
Wait.
I can't catch me.
The shadows can't catch me if I swim under.
Wait, where is the shadow?
Oh nevermind.
Guess I drowned.
He's so relaxed now.
He went back to the sea.
He returned to the ocean.
That's how relaxed he is.
He like devolved.
When you're so relaxed, you just devolved.
Yay!
That's where I'm gonna put my toilet.
I'm doing it, guys!
I'm becoming a master massage therapist!
Oh, is a giant lurking underneath the temple?
But, well, it is not.
What kind of colossus is that?
I think we're making really good progress.
I'm gonna look at my dead girlfriend now.
Hello, dead girlfriend.
Don't worry.
Apparently you're worth it.
I swear.
If you break up with me after I did all of this.
I swear to God.
Okay.
Let me...
Time to go find my girlfriend.
Time to go find the other colossus.
That would be very tragic.
I'd feel so sorry for this kid.
What?
I don't worry, boyfriend.
That got so dark.
Alright.
Time to pray.
Pray.
Pray to save.
Alright.
Where do we go?
Arlo, where do we go?
Arlo!
We go...
This way.
Alright.
Alright, Arlo.
You know what?
Let us do...
I know this is a short stream today.
But I think that is a good place to stop.
Stop it.
I think six... what?
Five bosses?
I think five bosses was good progress.
Five bosses was pretty good progress.
I did pretty well.
I'm pretty sure.
Doki's massage clinic is growing.
And I'm very proud of.
I am very proud of me, the kid, and Arlo.
We are doing so well.
Aren't we, Arlo?
Our business is growing.
It's booming.
People are spreading the glory of Doki's massage therapy.
It's to die for.
Doki's massage clinic.
No, I just got it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where are Pico?
Look.
They have... it's because like...
They're not stressed out yet.
Okay?
You think they're just going to be stressed out instantly?
Afterwards?
Chat?
It takes a while.
They just need to build up their...
They're trying to build up the oil for me to like...
The blood oil for me to release it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The horse is going to be called Jared by the time the last colossus is treated.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
Did I save?
I saved, right?
By praying?
Yeah.
So I don't have to worry.
I don't have to worry.
Whoa.
Wait.
This is not the right...
Why is it the game?
But what if...
Hey guys.
This is going to be the donation area now.
Tune in next time for Colossus Donkey.
Bye.
You know what?
I'm fine with this being my...
I'm fine with this being my chatting screen.
This works.
This is so good.
It's been fun so far.
I'm glad you guys are helping me not get absolutely fucking lost and helping me, helping me figure out where helping me figure out the controls is definitely very helpful.
It's so helpful.
But it's been really fun though.
So, it's been really fun so far.
Hey, what are you looking at?
What are you looking at, huh?
Yes, I wasn't as lost as I thought I was gonna be.
But I've definitely enjoyed it so far.
I can't wait to kill more Colossus.
Kill 16 Colossus, not 17.
I don't care about the hidden one.
The hidden one does not exist for me.
It's hidden for a reason.
I don't know if I'll ever be able to find the hidden one.
Oh, we're finally gonna do Super Chat reading!
We haven't done Super Chat reading in so long!
So I'm happy to be able to finally catch up on it.
Unless YouTube is down.
Okay, no.
Thank God.
Okay.
I was gonna say, where the fuck...
Where the fuck was my Super Chats?
Alright.
Don't worry, I was able to turn it on real fast.
Uhh...
Let's see.
Dr. Cranberry, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mother, I require chicken, grass, and maple leaves.
Please, Mother, I require sustenance.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you're enjoying the emotes.
Umm... let's see.
Micro, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doggy.
Congrats on the Razer sponsorship.
Oh!
It's not really a sponsorship.
It's more so they sent me some gifts.
Umm... so it's not like... it's not a sponsor.
It's like, uh, they just sent me some gifts, uh, and like some free products to try out.
So I'm not, like, sponsored by them.
If I am, I'll let you guys know, because it's illegal to, like, not put the hashtag.
Like...
Hahaha!
It's... it's illegal to not put, like, a hashtag if it was sponsored.
So... so it's more so, like, they just sent me some gifts to... to... uh... to try out.
Yeah, free is free.
I love free stuff.
Umm... but there is a sponsor this week that I'm really, really excited about.
Umm... it's sort of like a dream sponsor.
So, uh, yeah!
I don't know when exactly.
I know it's like around this week.
Umm... but when you see it, you'll know.
You'll... you'll... you'll know when you see it.
But... I'm super excited about it, though.
I'm super excited.
Any hints?
I'll just say it's like a dream sponsor.
Uhhhh... what else?
Let's see.
Mad!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I shot Shadow of in a similar art style.
I thought Eldering DLC came out and got hyped for a second.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Shadow of the Colossus walked.
So... wait, actually no.
Wait, actually no.
Demon's Souls sort of came out before Shadow of the Colossus.
Nevermind.
Uh... they both... they were both hand in hand walking together.
Uh... thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Uh... Pickle!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Zachary!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
We're getting old, Doki.
Thank you!
Uh... nice.
Chimera!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
You say that like Dan isn't closer to 50 than Forge... Bro!
Like, Dan from Game Grumps?
He looks so fucking young...
Um... for like how old he is.
Like... it's actually crazy.
I remember when like... when I first started watching Game Grumps and I found out he's like...
Like what?
Like... like a lot older than Eren.
And then I... cause like he looked younger than him.
So it's actually... he has like really good genetics, that's for sure.
Vance!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Hi Doki.
It's my birthday.
But I wanted to wish you a happy birthday as well!
And it says happy birthday.
Can you insult me for being a discord mod?
I don't have to insult you for being a discord mod.
Because you're...
You... You already did the job for me.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Speaking of Game Grumps, today is JonTron's birthday.
He's 34 now.
Thank you, thank you.
It's actually crazy.
A lot of the content creators I watched growing up, they're all like in their mid-30s to 40s.
I think like the craziest part is that you see them all the...
Okay, I think this... okay, I'm not gonna name any creators but I think the funniest ones are the ones that are in their 30s to 40s and like... oh my gosh.
No, I shouldn't say it.
Nevermind.
It's mean.
I shouldn't say it.
I didn't say it.
No, I'm talking about... okay.
I was gonna say it.
The ones that are doing...
Oh my god.
The ones that are doing Roblox stuff.
And they're like... cause like, you know, they started out Roblox content and they're maybe in their 30s.
Or maybe in their 20s.
And they're still doing Roblox content and they're like in their 40s.
I don't know.
I don't...
Look!
Money is money!
I understand!
Okay, I'm not gonna touch Minecraft.
Like, the Minecraft part.
This is why I don't... I'm not into like...
Like, I'm into... I like just casually playing Minecraft.
But the Minecraft community is like a whole nother section of do not touch.
Like...
Like, the Minecraft community section is just... I'm not...
It's like, they're saying...
Places you don't touch.
And like, you don't try to get into.
Like, the Minecraft community is one of them.
Like, I... I try to avoid what the fuck is going on in that area of community.
It's more so of like, the younger the audience.
Because it's like...
Okay, this is how... This is my...
Um, this is my opinion.
But I think like...
The younger your audience base is...
The harder it is...
To control the community.
And like...
And the harder it is...
To like...
Um...
How do I say?
Things will get...
Like...
Shit...
Lots of drama.
I think.
The younger the community...
The more...
Like...
The more controversies and drama comes to be.
So that is why...
If you are under 13 and you're watching my stream...
You are not supposed to have...
A YouTube account.
Unless you have a YouTube kids account.
But even then...
If you have a YouTube kids account...
You should not be able to watch this stream.
And don't say...
I'm 13.
Because you can actually get banned.
I'll say that now.
Like...
You're gonna be like...
I'm 13.
Or like...
I'm 12.
You can actually get banned by YouTube.
If you're...
If you say that.
So don't tell us your age.
Do not tell us...
Don't dox your age.
Do not dox your age.
But like...
I just feel like...
Personally...
This is my opinion.
But definitely...
Like...
If the community of like...
A fandom...
Or like...
A particular...
Just a particular community...
A majority of their audience...
Of like...
Whatever like...
You know...
Majority of the audience...
Are like...
Kids.
Like...
That's a lot of issues.
Like there's a lot of problems and issues.
Because you can't control children.
Children...
We're...
I was a stupid child.
I was a fucking stupid child.
That like...
Thought I was the smartest person in the whole wild world.
I'd be like...
I'm smarter than...
Like...
I'll be like...
You're like 25.
But I'm smarter than you.
Because my opinions...
Matter more.
And then...
But like...
Our brains are still fucking growing.
And...
Back...
Now I think my brain stopped growing.
Uh...
And...
Um...
And like...
I...
I don't wanna argue with a child.
Like...
I don't...
I don't wanna argue with a child to see who's right or wrong.
Like I don't have time for that.
I have to worry about like...
Fucking...
Bills and taxes.
I don't have time to argue about...
With you about...
What your opinion is.
I just...
Bro...
I'm stressed...
About...
Real life issues.
And...
Um...
That's why I was like...
I...
I like...
I try to stay away...
In terms of like...
Communities that are more...
Like...
Children centric.
Because like...
I feel like...
I just...
I just feel like...
From experience...
Not just like...
Not just...
From...
Current...
But even like...
In the past...
On the internet history...
The younger your audience is...
Or like...
The main audience...
Like I...
Like if you're...
If you're young and you're watching me...
I'm fine...
I'm cool with you.
Don't worry.
But I'm talking about like...
You know...
If the main audience base...
Is just kids...
Is mature...
Like 80% children...
It's so hard to control that type of community.
I don't know.
Because especially...
Especially if they are teenagers and...
We all know when you're a teenager...
You love to rebel.
It's playing with fire.
But yeah...
That's why I try...
I...
I'm scared.
Lolly...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
The horse is sweating.
How dare you!
Apologize to Arlo!
I don't know what his real name is.
Apparently, he's a she.
How was I so... Okay, guys, I like how you guys are like...
Arlo is a she!
Guys, how would I know the gender of this horse?
They never mention it!
I don't have a game guide to look at.
Okay?
I know... This is what I actually miss.
This is... You can tell bish...
You can see... What if they just remove it because they want the game to be PG?
Not every game has genitals!
Except for Genitals.
But not every game has genitals!
You don't know that!
Okay.
Anyway...
What's the last Guardian?
The last Guardian... That game...
Was that bird thing...
A guy or a girl?
Was the bird thing a guy or a girl?
Tell me.
Guys, I need to know.
Hahaha!
Yes!
Yeah!
Where the fuck was the genitals?
There was no giant pee-pee!
Bird pee-pee!
Oh wait, birds don't have pee-pees.
Sorry.
I forgot.
But it was like a...
A griffin.
So like...
It was half bird.
Maybe the down half was not a bird.
Hahaha!
I forgot about that.
Birds don't have pee-pee.
All of it comes from one hole.
Umm...
The bottom half didn't have to be a bird!
It could be a mammal.
The bottom half could be a mammal.
Yes, the lion half.
Yes, exactly.
The lion half!
Guys, where the fuck was that pee-pee?
No!
So games doesn't necessarily mean...
It doesn't mean that...
It'll show the genitals!
It doesn't mean that!
Anyway...
What I really miss too...
Is the game guides.
Oh my gosh, I miss...
I miss it when like...
When you buy a game, like a physical copy...
And then it includes like...
An actual game guide of like...
All the cool stuff about the lore and everything.
But they don't do that anymore because...
Like, you know...
You don't have to pay more money.
And everyone buys digitally now.
Everyone does digital...
Buy digitally now.
Like, save money!
We don't have to fucking hire a translator...
To translate the fucking instruction manual.
And also we don't have to hire somebody...
To write this up.
And also saves like the paper too.
The paper money.
Rock, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Getting lost, wanting backseat.
What I'm hearing is Doki needs other wiles in life.
The game that attracts backseaters.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's see.
The good old days.
When the game manual sometimes didn't even include the controls.
And was just a short story intro.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fudge top.
Thank you for the super chat.
Puzzle games with Doki is just chat plays with funny anime girl on the bottom right.
Talking about the weirdest things in the world.
Weird Doki's brain cells.
Piloting the tomato.
Piloting the skin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I am pretty sure the more I am as a streamer, the more stupid I have become.
I'm pretty sure.
There's no way.
I'm pretty sure I've actually lost brain cells from streaming.
I never read those game guides and just winged it.
But it was nice to have.
Thank you for the super chat.
I just like it when they include concept art too.
That's what I loved about it.
I remember as a kid just looking at the concept part and everything.
And then the strategy guides too.
They don't make strategy guides anymore.
Because you can just fucking YouTube.
No commentary playthrough.
Bro I used to own so many strategy guides.
I owned all the Pokemon.
Majority of the Pokemon strategy guides that came out.
I had to watch the next one too.
The ones that come with free posters.
We don't do that.
We just watch the no commentary.
They still make them.
Who buys them?
Who the fuck?
How do they make enough money to still make them?
I'm so confused.
How?
I'm surprised they still make enough money to manufacture the strategy guides.
Next one.
Thank you for the AkaSupa.
I can feel the stress leaving my body already.
Another happy customer.
Thank you for the AkaSupa.
Thank you.
Do people even buy the collector's editions?
I know that games nowadays they do collector's editions.
Stuff like that.
I'm wondering if people still...
Gosh.
I swear a lot of the collector's editions are so mediocre too.
I feel like there hasn't been really good collector's editions lately.
Because a lot of them are just incredibly mediocre.
I'm trying to remember.
There was a really bad one recently.
It was like... they kind of suck now.
I feel like they kind of just like capitalize on people just wanting to buy collector's editions because they are the fear of missing out and things like that.
Because they are like, oh I don't want to miss out.
It's limited edition.
There was a really shitty one.
Is it the Fallout 76 one?
The Fallout... oh yeah.
The Fallout 76 one was pretty fucking bad.
And sometimes the figures are so ugly too.
It's like the quality control is just not even worth it.
They make sure like the...
They make sure like the pictures for it is really really pretty.
And then because they grab the sample copy for the figure and then when you get it, it's just a very cheaper version of the manufactured, mass produced version of the figure and it's like not the best.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's just to trap you in to buy the collector's edition.
I also think... but like the thing that sucks that we are all going to digital now for like... I think the thing that sucks the most regarding like us transitioning to like digital copies of things is just the fact that when they take down the game itself,
like there's no way to play the game anymore like legally and I think that's the worst part because everything... there's no more physical copies.
So like I think they've been doing that for movies and TV shows now and like I'm...
I'm... the thing that people... oh did you guys see?
A lot of people are really worried that when Gabe, you know, cause he's getting older.
I know like some of us know Gabe is gonna live forever.
He's a god.
He's gonna live forever.
But did you guys hear how like people are like worried that when Gabe like retires or like um or like is not here anymore that the Steam is gonna like start being like heavily regulated and stuff by whoever purchases... like whoever whoever owns Steam after Gabe leaves.
Because he's the CEO.
He's the CEO.
And like a lot of people are now like really worried at the moment because if you guys didn't know, Gabe the reason why Steam is like the way it is is because like every time like the shareholders or like stock people or like the board tells them to do something,
Gabe is like NO!
FUCK OFF!
He's like cause people will be like no you should do this Gabe.
We will have more profit.
And Gabe is just like NO!
FUCK OFF!
Yeah it's a private company.
Yeah it's like a private company.
So he's just like I'm not gonna... I'm not gonna worry about that cause people are like no if you do this this you do my... there's gonna be more money involved.
But Gabe doesn't care.
He just wants to do a game.
Like he wants to like uphold his philosophy when it comes to games.
And um...
And that's what people are like really worried about too.
Yeah there's no board but I'm saying like if they're like people are like encouraging him to to like people are encouraging him to do that but he always rejects it.
He always says no.
And and that's what people are really worried right now cause they're like obviously if Gabe steps down or like he's not the CEO anymore.
Like people are like oh no.
Like is it gonna go public?
Is Steam gonna become is Steam gonna become public?
Cause we don't know!
We don't know who's gonna succeed him.
Um...
It's just... it's scary.
Hehehehehehehehehehe It's so scary cause like what like oh man like what's gonna happen to the gaming market too.
Everyone's like really worried right now.
I saw like so many articles talking about it being like uh just like oh what is Gabe what's gonna happen to Steam after Gabe steps down.
Um...
Hey thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
I can't even see the ending because I missed a chance.
Imagine that for hundreds of full price games.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
I know it's actually really scary for the future of gaming.
If Steam becomes like public I think it'll be like really uh it might it's gonna be really weird.
Hahahaha It's gonna be weird.
I was so sad when they took down the infinity train.
I actually the infinity train has to be like one of my most favorite animated shows.
It's so well done.
And like there's no way to watch it legally because they actually wiped infinity train off the internet like for legal means of watching it.
And it's like um the lore for it was so interesting.
I really like the lore.
Um...
And there's like there's so many like animated shows too that that like they took down and everything.
Uh... it's not yeah it's a scary thing to go full digital because you just don't know when something's just gonna be gone.
Hahahaha Cause there was no physical copies of infinity train.
Yeah they removed it for tax purposes.
It's always like that.
I don't understand.
I'm not smart enough to understand like why they removed things for tax purposes.
Because I feel like the government shouldn't like I feel like the government shouldn't you know endorse stuff like that.
Hahahaha Hahahaha I don't know.
Um... I don't know.
I just feel like you know the government shouldn't be pushing for you know writing things off for tax purposes.
But I don't know maybe they get bribed.
Who cares?
I mean I care but like at that point it feels like yeah that's right.
Hahahaha Thanks.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We go all digital and really bad solar storm hits.
We're all going to be screwed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hahahaha I'm still really sad about uh I'm still really sad about the Wall-E vs Acne movie not being out.
Did you hear about that?
Like okay I always talk about it but like the recent update.
Was that apparently the Wall-E vs Acne uh the movie um they said that oh what's his name?
I really like this actor.
The what was his name?
The main actor.
The main actor in that movie was like okay I understand it was like I watched a movie and it was Will was it it was Will Arnett.
Was it Will?
No not Will Arnett.
God it's one of the Wills.
Will Forte.
Why are every why is every comedian Will?
It's like every Hollywood actor is named Chris but this time every fucking comedian is named Will.
Will Ferrell.
Will Forte.
Will Arnett.
Anyway Will Forte.
He was the main actor for it.
Why?
Why is he in the movie?
And then um and then he was like I watched the movie and I thought they took it down because it was a fucking terrible movie.
And Will Forte has been in a lot of terrible movies.
So like I trust his opinion on what is a terrible movie.
And like no offense to him but he's been in a lot of them because as a comedian you're in a lot of terrible movies as a comedian and like at that point a paycheck is a paycheck and it's very hard to write a good comedy.
To write a good comedy movie you actually have to be like really smart.
Like I feel like a good comedian is um uh has to be like incredibly smart in order to write something actually funny.
Uh anyway sorry Wiley kind of anyway as I was saying and then he was tweeted out and he was like I don't understand why this movie is getting written off because this movie is actually really fucking good.
So I'm like why?
Fucking delete any of the other other fucking cartoon shows or movies for tax purposes.
The Looney Tunes is like one of your biggest properties.
Like everybody loves the Looney Tunes.
Why would you do this?
Who cares about Okay but who honestly cares about the new Velma season 2?
Everybody watched Velma to hate watch it.
Like honestly.
The only reason why Velma was doing so fucking well was because people were just hate watching it and they just wanted to like live tweet their hate for the show and they weren't actually watching it because they like it.
It was like a train wreck that people couldn't take their eyes off.
So people were like oh my god I hate this show so much but I'm not going to stop watching it because I want to know what they're gonna do next that's gonna make me hate it even more.
Um Anyway but yes I'm still so upset that I just want to watch Wildy Coyote vs Acme because it just seems like such a good fucking.
It just seems like such a good movie.
I really love Looney Tunes in general.
I honestly love that um which one except for Space Jam 2 that was just I can't believe Space Jam 2 didn't get cancelled for tax purposes.
I don't know.
I don't know what the purpose is.
Like that was definitely for my that was just nostalgia beating but I I know like it might be a hot take but I really I actually really enjoyed um fuck what was that movie called?
I watched it like several times because I actually really enjoyed it.
Back in Action.
I actually really liked Looney Tunes Back in Action.
I know when it came.
I know it had like really shitty reviews but it's I personally thought it was a good movie.
I thought it was fun.
I thought it was yeah but when it came out.
When that movie came out it was a box off like was it a it was not good.
It like reviews were fucking terrible and um it did not make back its money.
It did not it did not make back its money at all.
Um but I enjoyed it as a as a kid.
I enjoyed watching it and I I watched rewatch it several times on DVD and it was a fun movie.
Yeah it flopped.
It actually flopped but I think it was pretty good.
I thought it was pretty good.
Um but I actually really enjoyed Looney Tunes in general so I'm just really sad that we don't have new Looney Tunes stuff.
Anyway I've been yapping a lot.
.
I'm gonna call it here guys.
I'm sorry I didn't read all the super chats.
I'm sorry I didn't read all the super chats but I'm getting eepy now.
So I'm gonna call it here everybody.
Um I hope you guys enjoyed Shadow of the Colossus Part 1.
As always everybody stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!